[Musique]
sac
3 je crois que ce que j'hésite entre
deux entre 18h et 21h30
non je crois que c'est 18 heures 22h40
le jeudi adacore pardon alors la
diffusion s'est s'installé le soir
paraison pardon vous précisez pas je
parle dans l'enregistrement
la grande marque a juste eu vraiment
l'aprem le 500e
il s'est marié avec camille combal
est-ce qu'il n'est pas identique avec
quelqu'un d'autre qui puisse moins
quelqu'un camille peut-être mokhtar 3g
je stresse on dirait je pense qu'au code
à oui mais ça je savais oui une fois
devant une fois las vegas j'étais là où
deux je pensais que celles avec des
combats une personne je suis différente
ah non là je les ai je ne mets pas moi
je pensais à des personnes différentes
autrement oui deux fois je me sens très
bien
[Musique]